is missing out on life
he was in an Israeli jail when his
four-month-old daughter Mira was born
and he was also imprisoned when Anwar
lost her twin babies born prematurely in
2020. the 48 year old has spent nearly
half of his life in Israeli military
jails
lately Israel has been detaining him
without a charge or trial
often jokingly tells me that I need to
build a life around him being with us
only for 2-3 months as he spends the
rest of the time in jail
under Israel's policy of administrative
detention Palestinians can be held in
jails indefinitely and now we have and
29 other Palestinian prisoners have
started the hunger strike demanding
Israel release them the Palestinian
detines commission says most of those on
Hunger Strike will move to our over
military prison in the occupied West
Bank and outside it Palestinian families
tend to show support for their loved
onesan has spent 14 years in prison he
was charged and sentenced to five of
them only he barely spends three to four
months outside of prison before Israeli
forces arrest him he usually spends more
than two years in administrative
detention this is unjust
since the beginning of this year Israel
has issued more than 1500 orders to hold
Palestinians without charge Israeli
military prosecutors often say they hold
secret evidence related to the prisoners
but human rights organizations say
Israel is using this policy as a
punishment to prevent Palestinians
leading a normal life
this is an arbitrary arrest and it's
considered a war crime for which Israel
should be held accountable the lack of
accountability is what forces
Palestinian prisoners to carry out
individual and Collective hunger strikes
unfortunately there is no real pressure
on Israel to end its policy of
administrative detention
through Israel's decades-long occupation
hunger strikes have been one of the main
tools used by prisoners to achieve their
demands in the past decade more than 400
have staged individual hunger strikes to
protest against Israeli prison policies
prisoners hope a collective strike would
mobilize support among people on the
street as there are few Palestinian
families who haven't had a member a
friend or relative get arrested since
1967.
the occupied Westbank